hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another sundance 2022
interview this one is with the fine
folks behind master
mariama regina zoe hello and
congratulations to all of you
thank you all right thank you
for having us so happy for you guys so
first with a festival screening many of
our viewers will not know much about
your movie just yet at least so mariama
would you mind doing the honors and give
every giving everyone a synopsis of
master
sure let me let me try to be as concise
as possible because i can be a little
bit uh you know wordy if i let myself
but uh master it's set at the fictional
ancestor college which is a northeastern
um very elite uh institution the town
that the school is in
um it goes all the way back to the salem
era and when we start the film we meet
gail bishop who is played by regina hall
and gail has just been promoted to a new
position of master which is basically
like headmaster or more like a dean of
students because there are several
masters in the college um and this is a
prestigious position but it comes with
as you can imagine a lot of baggage and
a lot of responsibilities one of gil's
responsibilities is to look after
um the freshmen who live in the house
the residence house one of them being uh
jasmine moore who's played by zoe renee
and uh jasmine unfortunately is um
assigned a dorm room that according to
the legend of the school is haunted um
this is you know just makes life a
little bit unpleasant for her and things
only get that much more complicated as
we get deeper into the semester i feel
like i was also using that synopsis to
figure out how far i can go in
explaining plot points without teetering
into spoiler territory
thank you uh this is also your feature
directorial debut which is a very big
deal getting a first feature off the
ground is not easy whatsoever so what do
you think was the key to getting the
green light whether it was a past credit
a person you met a piece of financing
you name it you know it was thank you
first of all um because i it
was very hard
and there was certainly a point where i
just couldn't tell
how to make it happen you know i've been
writing for years and years and just for
fun but i felt very very outside of the
film industry uh but the thing that i
think really made the difference for me
is that on you know the smallest scale
on the scale that i could manage i
started to create and so i made a couple
of short films i made a short film
called sketch and then i made a short
film called hair wolf where i kind of
tried to apply the lessons that i had
learned from the first one and you know
strengthen the film and that short was
lucky enough to get traction and you
know get play at festivals like sundance
and um and that's really what allowed me
to
you know start walking into meetings and
saying well i do have this script you
know i had uh
master was the most recent script that i
had written but i was in this phase
at that time for like a few years where
i was writing constantly so i had
actually a lot of scripts
master was the one that i liked the most
um but the timing just worked out that i
had the story that i really loved i
hadn't yet fallen out of love with it
which happens to me sometimes with some
of the scripts i write you know you
write it thinking it's going to be
brilliant and then you get to the end
and you're like i can never show my face
again um but this one i just i never
stopped loving it and so that felt like
a sign and then i got to actually you
know meet people who could help me make
it which is how i met my producers at
animal kingdom i love hearing that so
much all right regina so i was busy
scrolling through your imdb and it
caught my eye that you've got master and
also hunk for jesus save your soul next
both are feature directorial debuts for
their directors so it was just making me
wonder is working with new creators a
priority for you right now and then also
what is it about miriama that made you
say this right here is a person that i
should be taking a chance on
um i mean i think there's just so much
incredible talent out there that you
know i've always honored to be able to
to work with or and support in any way i
can and um
you know it's exciting when you're just
when you're able to do that so i think
meeting um reading her reading mariana's
work and then meeting her in person i
thought she was just incredibly smart
you know like incredibly wise her
enthusiasm i thought she was
um
so creative um
and
you know i was that was exciting to me
you know it is it's really exciting and
i think
um
you know when when rare opportunities
come and your gut is like this person
is really special you know you have to
like honor that you know because it's
it's um
you know in a way you know
it's divine and so it's like
you know you it's so it's a weird thing
when you're when you're when you decide
to say yes because you don't know what's
come before you and like you know for me
i never think of like a role
first or second i think what third for
you it's like when you and that person
meet then you say yes then it all makes
sense and you're like oh yes i'm
supposed to and it on so many levels and
i learned a lot from her working on this
and
i think she's
so incredible and i think you know the
um
the
world of film the world of cinema
television whatever we're just we're
really
um
blessed to have her and um
of course it's wonderful when you meet
talented women you know what i mean and
it's like just to have you know we have
a female director we have a female dp
um shout out to charlotte um and then um
a script that's centered around women
and you know to have a script that's
centered around women it's very smart
and to have dynamics of
of race and gender be um so
intelligently and wisely and
entertainingly explored um you know i i
mean it was just kind of a no-brainer so
i you know i really feel excited by um
noriyama and by adama so it's you know i
gotta
i got lucky
i feel like those those gut reactions
and those types of connections are what
so many of the gems that we get in this
industry are built on rather than you
know like a piece of paper with a list
of things that you would expect in order
to you know commit to something like
that so
i applaud that very very much so zoe
this is i believe it's your second
feature film in a lead role so looking
back is there anything that you are able
to do on master that you know you can
credit two lessons learned while making
gin
oh it's a great question yeah i think
that um you know with with jen we shot
for one month in
la pretty gorilla style we kind of just
picked up the camera and went
um i think the ability to kind of
release anything that i thought that i
would go into my day with
um i learned on gin to just
release expectations um go into it
honest and
um put
the character and the work that we've
done first and and
stop trying to be so perfect at
everything and just kind of allow the
story to speak and
my cast mates to speak to me and to
allow real and honest moments happen i
think
jyn probably taught me that the most
definitely shines through you're talking
to a perfectionist i understand that too
well with the earnestness in your work
here it's just spot on congratulations
on that
so regina clearly i'm very obsessed with
scream so probably comes as no surprise
that i watched the scary movie franchise
quite a bit and it has made me wonder as
someone who's been part of you know a
long a long-running horror spoof series
how is that influenced how you felt
about genre in general because you know
if i have my titles right i feel like
master might mark your first non-spoof
horror movie or i guess when the bow
breaks counts but it's it's a little
more in the thriller territory i guess
yeah
gosh i don't you know i i i love all
genres
um
when they're done well you know so i
felt really lucky to be doing the the
spoof genre with the weigh-ins because i
feel like keenan really understood it
and
and i loved screen too i actually
watched it um
so it feels great and to do this it's so
you know the way i think my armor wrote
the script and the way she directed it
it's so grounded
and it's so real and there are things
obviously that are suspended you know
but it just it almost
it's like
you know whatever world you're getting
to in whatever genre it's really it's
it's really real you know it's crazy as
it sounds brenda was really real like
you know you weren't playing the parody
you're not playing the
horror it's just like you kind of go
into this world you go into these
characters you go into these
relationships and what's great about
having a director and a really good
director and a director like mariama is
you know she's watching the monitor and
she's watching your performance and
she's fine-tuning it and helping you
create nuances that you know are so
subtle um
and giving you kind of the opportunity
to do it until you until it clicks and
so i i think
you know i feel really i feel really
blessed but but uh uh
you know
we won't be parody
imagine brenda parody and gayle but no i
i think it's um i don't maybe maybe
brent is a professor i think i was a
teacher by the last one but i think what
what is but i think it's i think it's so
wonderful to be able to
um i love how movies navigate across so
many genres and i love that someone like
you can appreciate
one to the other to the next and you
know different generations and
i i don't know i i find it to be quite
entertaining to play and challenging but
fun
speaking of that mariama this i mean it
almost feels like an unfair question but
it's also something that i think would
highlight one of my favorite qualities
of this film can you put this in a genre
for our viewers
so
i
at the beginning of the process of
writing the film and talking to people
about it i always described it as a
spooky drama
that is that is the made-up genre that i
would place this in
i think that you know at its core you
know there's this you know in intense
dramatic you know story going on and
that's really what girds the entire
thing but it's horrific you know that's
also true i would call it a horror film
as well you know i think that
horror
our understanding of it you know it's
constantly in flux and they're like you
know there are horror films that
might seem
you know that they don't belong in the
same category that this one doesn't
belong in the same category as them but
then there are other ones that i think
that you know this lives uh you know
within alongside them so i think that um
i think i would call it a horror film uh
since spooky drama is a
term
this is why i've fallen into the habit
of saying genre instead of horror
because then everything can be included
uh so zoe you get to work with a pretty
incredible ensemble here just so we
could highlight maybe a couple of names
are there any instances where i don't
know maybe you were having a tough time
accessing something in your own
character but because of what someone
else gave you as a scene partner on set
you were able to reach that thing
absolutely i i can think about
our first day back on set and uh
mariama
was one of my biggest just emotionally
draining scenes
i'm crying i'm running around and you
know she's pushing me in the sweetest
way but also pushing me wanting me to
get to this this point um where jasmine
is is really struggling and uh
you know her comfort and her guidance
was was genuinely just
invaluable it it helped me for the rest
of shooting and of course we have to
talk about this miriam we went into the
craziest scene first day back on on to
master um but she was so amazing and
then i can't even begin to
talk about regina the hall because uh
she she really is just a light i mean i
think our our most
um tender moments were in the makeup
trailer or passing
passing each other you know going to our
trailers this sense of community and
love and
you know regina had only known me at
that point for like
maybe a couple days but i felt like she
had my back and she really did and i uh
even on set i i remember feeling like i
was
really walking side by side
regina hall and it's still to this day
i'm i'm not sure how to
process it but i'm trying and you know
all these moments are
setting in in stone so they're amazing
they really are
hearing about community on set like that
always makes me very happy
i have to let you all go soon but i'll
squeeze in one more here mariama i was
reading in the press notes that
someone had emphasized how good you are
at using your imagination to solve
problems so obviously that made me
wonder can you give us i guess a
non-spoiler example of doing that on
this film like a day that didn't go to
plan a resource you couldn't afford or
whatever it was but you came up with the
creative solution to still make it work
and maybe work better than what you had
originally planned before
yeah so
as you can imagine the need for that
like kind of skill set
was immense
and um
there there are
a bunch of examples coming to mind but
like for one um
one that was uh
tough and it all worked out
was that um there
there was a scene that we needed to
shoot and um
because of
covid our actor was not available and
the location
then was no longer available
so
we but it was a very very important
scene um
and really important to the film so it's
not like something that we could just
let go so we needed to figure out a way
to shoot the scene in one of the you
know locations that we still had left to
go and i do think that it made it better
i rewrote the scene you know i basically
got home that night and you know thought
okay well we have this scene happening
here i need to transpose it uh to
another a location with all of these
same people you know so i need to you
know come up with a compelling reason
that they would all be gathered because
it was like a few people um and and i'm
so happy like i'm so so happy that we
weren't able to shoot in our original
location and the scene itself changed
and i i like it so much more
i'm so curious specifically what that is
we'll have to save that for another time
when master comes out i got a million
more questions i could ask you all right
now but you have a very busy sundance
schedule so i will say thank you for
spending some time with us and huge
congratulations on master